10 percent of Americans have depression
they tell you it's all chemical
imbalance in the brain that's a lie some
of it may be but depression is also a
product of living a life you're not
supposed to be living and if your
mercenary wife and all the political
Consultants around you tell you you have
to be in the U.S Senate and you don't
want to be in the U.S Senate you're not
ready to serve in the U.S Senate maybe
it gives you depression that's not crazy
actually is an explanation those people
should have to answer for it who did
this to him
so it's kind of interesting that you're
not hearing our leaders talk that much
about black people anymore remember all
the neoliberals were obsessed telling
you about black people why aren't they
talking about black people anymore three
years after George Floyd actually the
lives of many African-Americans real
people have gotten a lot worse
following the 2020 Floyd riots
African-American deaths by homicide
reached levels never seen before in this
country
someone should stop and ask why is that
but no one no one in the Democratic
party is because they don't care they
don't have to care because they have a
new class of victims to exploit for
political power out with black people in
with transgenderists
we're going to exploit their suffering
to become more powerful and of course
big corporations are taking the lead as
they always do Bud Light just honored a
man who dresses up like a little girl
called Dylan Mulvaney watch this
I got some Bud Lights for us so I kept
hearing about this thing called March
Madness and I thought we were all just
having a hectic month but it turns out
it has something to do with sports and
I'm not sure exactly which sport but
either way it's a cause to celebrate
this month I celebrated my day 365 a
Womanhood and Bud Light Sent Me possibly
the best gift ever a can with my face on
it
so do you think that the people in
charge care about that person
or any transgender person really if they
did they might ask questions like is the
suicide rate among young people who are
getting hormone treatments rising or
falling because if you cared you'd want
to know that they don't want to they
don't care you think Sandy Cortez even
thinks about that no the point is
getting power from the suffering of
others and if you've decided you're
another sex you're definitely suffering
on many many levels but point that out
and you get attacked that happened to
our friend billboard Chris in Canada he
went to a
trans rally in Vancouver on Friday
here's what happened to him while there
so who's the aggressor there well it
wasn't the man who calls himself
billboard Chris he was assaulted and
when he reported his assault to the air
quotes here police the police refused to
investigate
within seconds I was surrounded
not allowed to walk freely
pushed as you can see my nose is
bleeding they just walked up to him
insulted him you want to see I don't
where's the video
I have it on my camera right now yeah I
can show it to you
how about you show it to me are you
gonna do something about it if I do
uh if I actually see an assault and not
I claim him
do you think he did it to himself or
something uh people can do these things
to hurt themselves on purpose you don't
honestly thinks you're here thinking I
scratched myself on purpose this is
hilarious
oh The Rosy cheeked face of tyranny she
could be working in the City Bank HR
department maybe she will be someday
the only one the police chief the deputy
police chief Rother Howard Chow of
Vancouver has taken her side he says
he's appalled not the people were being
bashed in the face for their political
views but because some people don't like
the fact the police didn't respond he
hasn't condemned the militants who
attacked that man that's because in
Canada as in this country militants with
the right cause the trans cause can do
whatever they want they can even kill
Christian children in school
and they're
they're the victims
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight